The first known disaster in the Final Destination
franchise takes place in Victorian England
in 1889, when rising gas from some underground
construction causes the explosion of a house
at Number 4 Mornington Crescent.
Thanks to the vision of the young girl Juliet
Collins, there are seven survivors, but one
by one, Death would reclaim them.
Newsman Matthew Upton was impaled by a chemical
filled pipe, historians Hector Barnes, Jane
Stanley and their protégé Andrew are poisoned
by snakebite, surgeon Stewart Tubbs inhales
a poisonous gas and serial killer Bill Sangster
is caught in the gears of a drawbridge.
These events are the first known example of
what I’ll be calling the Flight 180 phenomenon,
where accident survivors are picked off one
by one after avoiding Death.
This usually happens when a clairvoyant, a
character with an ability to foresee future
events, has a vision of his or her own death
and saves their own life, and possibly the
lives of others, forcing Death to change its
ways to reclaim its rightful victims.
There is a lot of mystery surrounding Death.
Is Death just a force of nature, no different
than time or gravity?
Or is it an entity, a grim reaper with it’s
own thoughts, plans and vulnerabilities?
In this video I’ll be analyzing every death
in the series, including the ones that occur
off screen, in the novels and in the comics.
This video is sponsored by Hunt a Killer.
Welcome to Horror History.
Before I continue on with the history of Death,
which is essentially the Final Destination
timeline, here are a couple of disclaimers.
For this video, I’ll be using the sequel
timeline.
In the first Final Destination movie, we see
that Flight 180 crashed on May 13, 1999.
However, in the sequels, that date has been
moved to May 13th, 2000, and I’ve theorized
that this has something to do with the line
in the first movie, where Alex looks up at
the stars and wonders if there could be a
world where the Flight 180 passengers are
still safe.
Second disclaimer -- there is at least one
premonition incident that we don’t know
the details of that occurs before the other
accidents.
“It’s just that I’ve seen this before.
A lucky few survive a disaster, and
one by one Death comes for them all.”
I’ve theorized that this could be William
Bludworth’s own near-death experience, but
as of right now, we don’t know for sure.
Third disclaimer.
Outside of the movies, there are also Final
Destination novels and comics.
While they don’t seem to directly contradict
the canon of the movies from what I can tell,
they are out of print.
Not having access to all of them, it’s hard
to say when they all take place chronologically,
so I’ll start with the ones that I can’t
place in the timeline.
With that all being said, let’s get into
it.
In Final Destination: Dead Reckoning, punk
rock singer Jess Golden saves some lives with
her vision of a collapsing nightclub.
The bouncer Sebastian, is later killed by
his exploding motorcycle, a student named
Amber is run over by an out of control car,
a jock named Charlie falls down an elevator
shaft, a cop named Marina is poisoned by a
black widow, a waitress named Macy is struck
by a metal pane, an alcoholic named Ben falls
into a manhole, and a drug dealer named Eric
is hit in the head with a surfboard.
The book also describes what is perhaps the
only visual depiction of Death’s true form.
In Jess’s dreams, she sees a horrific monstrosity
of shifting bones and corpses that supposedly
represent Death.
Several months later, Jess and her friend
Jamie are nowhere to be found, so it’s unknown
if they found a way to beat death.
In Final Destination: Destination Zero, journalist
Patti Fuller learns she had a great grandmother
who once cheated death by being revived after
she drowned in a river.
Patti had her own vision, and foresaw the
bombing of the South Hill Metroline in Los
Angeles.
She managed to get some people off the train
before it happened.
The survivors include Hal, who later drowned
in a flash flood, Zack, a construction man
who was cut in half by a glass pane, and Susan,
a mechanic who was burned to death.
Then there was Al, who was beheaded by a flying
hubcap while receiving what I will refer to
as mobile pipe cleaning service by a professional…
named Candi, and Will who was impaled by CDs
and DVDs from a now defunct electronics store.
I’m guessing that is NOT just what he needed.
"You're just what I needed!"
Patti eventually dies of an intentional overdose
so that she can be revived, and theoretically
go on living just as her great grandmother
once did many years ago.
In Final Destination: End of the Line, recent
high school grad Danny King has a vision about
a train crash at 32nd Street in New York City.
This time, the survivors include Rinoka, who
is crushed by a bathtub that falls through
the floor; Peter, who is impaled by the horns
of a gazelle; Jack, who falls onto a wine
corkscrew that impaled him in the eye; Mary-Beth,
who is butchered by a chainsaw dropped by
a construction worker; and Bodil and James,
who are both part of a wild series of events
culminating in them being thrown from the
top of a moving truck into a store display
of umbrellas that impale them.
The last two remaining are Danny and his sister,
Louise.
What happens to them is very interesting,
and potentially exhibits another rarely seen
ability of Death.
Louise tries to do what Patti Fuller did,
so she can technically die by injection but
be revived.
“Only new life can defeat Death.”
But when Louise comes back, she accidentally
cuts the brakes while adjusting her brother’s
motorbike, and in his final moments, Danny
realizes that Louise was only revived in order
to play a part in his Death.
This is significant because it means Death
has the ability to use the victims’ survival
tactics against them -- however, this alone
is not enough to prove that Death is a conscious
entity, rather than a natural phenomenon.
What happens to Louise afterwards is not known,
but the next novel, Final Destination: Dead
Man’s Hand would introduce a new facet that
would change our perception about Death in
the Final Destination franchise.
The holiday gift grind is upon us.
I seriously don’t know what to get anyone
this year.
Clothes?
Nowhere to wear them.
Video games?
Yeah, like anyone wants to spend more time
watching screens after a long day of Zoom
calls, and also the priority for screens should
be on watching CZsWorld videos, because I’m
here to tell you about the perfect gift for
you or that horror fan in your life.
It’s the Blair Witch game from Hunt a Killer!
You’ve probably watched a horror movie and
thought, “Why would you get in a car with
a bunch of other people that the grim reaper
wants to kill?”
Well, this is your chance to see how you’d
fare in the middle of a Blair Witch story.
Over the course of a season, you’ll be in
charge of solving the mystery of Black Hills
Forest.
You’ll be sent 6 boxes containing realistic
evidence, maps, police reports and more to
provide a horrifying and immersive experience.
This is one of their best stories yet because
it feels like you’re stepping into a world
of Blair Witch lore.
Right now, Horror History viewers can go
to HuntAKiller.com/CZsWorld and
use CODE CZSWORLD, for 20% off your first
box.
Again, make sure to use CODE CZSWORLD for
a 20% discount and to show your support for
the show.
Can you survive the curse of The Blair Witch?
The next novel is Final Destination: Dead
Man’s Hand.
Allie Goodwin gets married to her ex-boyfriend
one drunk night in Vegas and saves five lives
when she foresees the glass elevator collapse
in a hotel called Merlin’s Tower.
Sure enough, Death comes for all of the escapees,
but unlike all of the disasters mentioned
so far, they do not die in the same order
they died in during the premonition, and this
is because of another rule of Death.
If someone intervenes with Death’s plans
and saves a life, that person will be “skipped”,
but Death will come back around for them after
completing its list.
Because of this, it starts with an exotic
dancer named Shawna who is rammed into a slot
machine by a special prize car that rolled
off of it’s display platform.
Guess it wasn’t her lucky day at the slots.
Her boyfriend, a man named Warren Ackerman,
dies shortly thereafter when a powerline falls
onto a puddle he’s standing in.
Then a gambling addict named Arlen is killed
during… a pipe cleaning disaster… involving
a severed pipe.
Death seems to have preferred methods of taking
people out, and I guess in the books it really
likes to… interrupt that clarinet practice…
Allie’s newlywed husband Thomas is hit by
a speeding truck, another commonly used tactic
of the reaper, but Allie’s death is much
less in line with the usual methods found
in the world of Final Destination.
After her initial premonition, she was sprayed
with blood by one of the victims she was unable
to save from the elevator, and once she is
the last remaining survivor, she finds out
that she contracted HIV from that blood.
We don’t see her death, but it’s heavily
implied that she does not survive.
This is perhaps the only subtle death among
those who cheated Death’s design.
I think William Bludworth’s explanation
is the best answer as to why so many of them
pass on in such a gruesome manner.
“The risk of cheating the plan, of disrespecting
the design, could incite a fury that could
terrorize even the grim reaper.
And you don’t even want to **** with that
mack-daddy!”
I think the basic implication is that if you
mess up Death’s original plan for you it’s
gonna be much scarier when your fate finally
does catch up with you.
Final Destination: Sacrifice is an interesting
departure from the standard formula, because
the protagonist has many prophetic visions.
The first is a bus accident, but he’s unable
to convince anyone else to get off the bus,
and he is the only survivor.
Next, he sees a factory explosion, and this
time he’s able to save himself and four
co-workers, but soon finds he has only delayed
each of their appointments with death.
After a ladder accident, a bathtub electrocution,
a lawn mower malfunction and a railroad splattering,
he once again finds himself the only survivor.
Next, he envisions himself and his family
dying in a gas explosion.
At this point he’s overwhelmed with grief,
and decides to hang himself, thinking that
if Death got what he wanted with him, the
people in his life would maybe no longer be in danger.
There are two ways to look at this story.
It could be that Death is not perfect, and
these first three attempts were unsuccessful,
or it could be that suicide was in the cards
for him all along.
There are a few other disasters referenced
in news articles, but it’s not clear when
they take place.
They include a building collapse that kills
14, a bus crash that takes 32, an electrical
fire that destroys an office, a capsized boat
resulting in the loss of 4 lives, a Ferris
wheel that sends 9 more souls to the afterlife,
an accident in the gulf that kills 18, a hardware
store accident that claims 2 (which we only
know to take place some time after April
of 2003).
That’s it for the ambiguously placed entries.
If you know when some of these take place,
please do drop me a comment.
From here on out, the order of events are
more clearly spelled out.
Which takes us to the end of April 2000.
The office employees of a New York branch
of Presage Paper set out on a business retreat,
but as their bus crosses the North Bay Bridge,
the structure starts to collapse.
A part time salesman named Sam Lawton has
a premonition, causing him to take his ex
girlfriend Molly Harper and flee the bus.
Six others give chase, and as a result, they
are the only survivors.
At the funeral for the deceased employees,
they encounter William Bludworth, who warns
them that Death does not like to be cheated,
and over the next couple days, each of them
would find out exactly what he means.
Intern Candice Hooper breaks her spine in
a freak gymnastics accident, tech expert Isaac
Palmer is taken out by a variety of accidents
during his massage therapy and board member
Olivia Castle falls out of a building after
having her vision impaired during a botched
Lasik surgery.
The next on Death’s list is factory supervisor
Nathan Sears, but he’s able to avoid Death’s
attempt, and an employee named Roy Carson
takes the fall instead.
According to William Bludworth’s theory,
this may have changed Nathan’s position
by adding Roy’s remaining lifespan to his
own.
“You shorted Death.
So you let Death have somebody else in your
place, and then you take their spot in the
realm of the living -- all the days and years
they’ve let to live.
And they take your place in Death.”
We never find out if Bludworth is telling
the truth here though, because as it turns
out Roy only had a couple days left to live
anyway.
“Turns out Roy had an enlarged blood vessel
in his brain so big, it was about to burst.”
And Bludworth is also pretty adamant that
you can’t escape Death, so it seems quite
possible that this letting Death have someone
in your place business is just an unproven
theory that he’s testing.
Otherwise you’d probably have a bunch of
immortal serial killers running around the
world of Final Destination.
This is New York… not Haddonfield.
It doesn’t take long for the boss, Dennis
Lapman, to be done in by a flying wrench.
Sales manager Peter Friedkin decides to take
out Molly, hoping to gain her years, but ends
up settling for an FBI Agent named Block instead,
shortly before Sam finishes him off with a…
what is this thing called?
I’ll just call it a meat skewer.
On May 13th, 2000, Sam and Molly decide
to start a new life together in Paris, but
before their flight takes off, a 17 year old
student named Alex Browning has a vision.
He sees the plane malfunction and explode,
causing him to freak out and demand to be
removed from the aircraft.
Six others from his French class are also
removed in the commotion.
Alex’s foresight comes true, and Sam and
Molly perish in the crash.
A piece of the aircraft flies back towards
the city and crushes Nathan and several others,
completing Death’s list from the North Bay
Bridge collapse.
But because 6 of the Mt. Abraham High School
students and one teacher got off the plane
that they should have died on, Death must
start a new list to clean up these survivors.
At this point, you probably have a lot of
questions.
The previous disasters that I’ve talked
about have been relatively self contained.
So if Sam had never had a vision, and the
Presage Paper employees had died on the bridge
collapse, would Flight 180 still have needed
to crash?
Or did Death take Sam’s vision into account?
Was the plan all along for him to survive
the bridge collapse so that he could die on
Flight 180?
The way I see it, once your time is up, your
time is up, and when that time comes, you
may be able to put it off a little bit, but
you really can’t change history; you can’t
alter the bigger picture.
I’ll be able to fully explain why by the
end of the video, but for now, think of it
like this.
If Sam had never had his vision, the Presage
employees would have died on the bridge, but
Flight 180 was always destined to crash whether
their seats were filled or not.
Because Sam and Molly did survive, Death altered
its schemes just slightly to put them on Flight
180, which was going to crash anyway.
From here, it just gets more and more complicated,
because Death’s new plans for the Mt. Abraham
students create a butterfly effect resulting
in new survivors, to be added to Death’s
growing list, as well as other disasters in
different parts of the world.
One of coolest things about Hunt a Killer's
Blair Witch game, is that you receive these
boxes of evidence and solve the mystery entirely
from home, but you still have that sense of
exploration.
They do such a good job a building this world,
you end up becoming totally immersed in these
locations and attached to the characters you're
trying to help.
If you love the slow burn pit in your stomach
type of horror, this is the alternate reality
game for you.
The story unfolds a little bit more with each
box, making it a satisfying adventure to take
on with a partner, but an equally rewarding
endeavor to solve on your own.
Just don't come crying to me if the Blair
Witch ends up in your nightmares.
Actually, on second thought.
I do want to know if that happens.
There's even an optional, spoiler-free online
community where you can collaborate with other
detectives to try solve difficult puzzles
or share your own theories about the characters
in the story.
This is your chance -- go to HuntAKiller.com/CZsWorld
and use CODE CZSWORLD, for 20% off your that
first box.
Again.
CODE CZSWORLD.
Twenty percent discount.
What else could you really ask for?
Alex Browning’s best friend Tod Waggner
is first up on Death’s new list, but before
Death reaches him, it’s likely that he did
something to extend the life of a man named
Evan Lewis, but we don’t really know exactly what.
All we do know is that Evan is added to a
new list, that Death would deal with later.
In June of 2000, Tod slips on some leaked
toilet water in his bathroom, ultimately causing
him to accidentally strangle himself on this
clothesline.
This is the point where I’d say we have
proof that Death is a force of nature, but
also a character, a grim reaper trying to
outsmart its victims, because after killing
Tod, it cleans up after itself by receding
toilet water to make Tod’s death look like
a suicide.
This was likely to throw off William Bludworth,
who was now giving advice to some of the accident
survivors.
Death didn’t want Bludworth metaling with
its plans.
It doesn’t work though, Bludworth is still
able to determine the real cause of Tod’s
death.
This tells me that Death is powerful, but
not perfect, and Bludworth’s teachings to
Flight 180 survivor Clear Rivers would continue
to be a problem for Death going forward.
The next Flight 180 student that Death reaches
is Terry Chaney, who is hit by a bus, but
this also causes a woman named Kat Jennings,
who was on that bus, not to reach the hotel
she was supposed to die at, so she is now
added to the second list behind Evan Lewis.
Death goes after the teacher that got off
of Flight 180, Valerie Lewton, by blowing
up her computer monitor, setting her home
on fire, and finally letting her drop a kitchen
knife into her own body.
Later that night, Alex saves his classmate
Carter Horton from being hit by a train.
Death skips Carter and moves onto the next
in line, Billy Hitchcock, who is killed by
a piece of scrap metal that shoots out from
under the train.
A police officer named Thomas Burke is dispatched
to investigate Billy’s death, causing him
not to be there for a shootout that kills
his partner.
Since Burke was also supposed to die in the
shootout, he is added to Death’s second
list.
The next day, a teacher named Eugene Dix is
called in to substitute for Ms. Lewton’s
class, causing him to be absent during an
attack that took place at the school he would
have otherwise been teaching at, so he too
is added to the second list.
It seems like Death is just letting this second
list grow until after it’s taken care of
the first list.
At some point Nora and Tim Carpenter are also
added to the second list, probably as a ripple
effect of something Alex Browning did.
Something he would not have been able to do
if he had died on Flight 180.
The next victim is Clear Rivers, but Alex
manages to save her, so the target moves to
him.
Six months go by before Death makes another
attempt.
With Clear’s warning and Carter’s quick
action, Alex’s life is saved.
Death cycles back through the list, so it’s
once again Carter’s turn.
He isn’t so lucky and he’s struck by a
fallen restaurant sign.
The commotion causes Rory Peters, who is nearby, to miss his show at a local theater, which would later collapse, and he would also be added to the second list.
Death makes dozens of attempts, going back
and forth between Clear and Alex, before finally,
Alex is knocked out of the picture by a falling
brick.
Clear goes into hiding in a padded room where
Death is unable to reach her.
This is another reason I think Death is more
of a character making conscious decisions,
because if it were simply a set of rules,
it wouldn’t move on to that second list
until Clear was taken care of.
But with Clear locked away in isolation, it
didn’t really matter if Death focused on
other things, because she was unlikely to
save any other lives while she was in there,
and if she did come out, Death would have
an opportunity to finish her.
But before that happens, is when I believe
the events of Final Destination: Spring Break
take place.
We know this happens around March, because
that’s when Spring Breaks tend to happen.
I think it’s in the year 2001 because it
seems to be after Flight 180.
There’s a point where a character sees that
her flight is also 180 and her eyes go wide.
But it can’t be too far into the 21st century.
They still have standard definition TVs in
the hotels.
Carly Hagan and her friends are vacationing
at the Hotel Grand Tzolk'in in Cancun, Mexico.
Before arriving, she has a premonition of
her hotel exploding.
When she sees the signs from her dream starting
to come true, she urges her friends to go
outside with her.
Because it’s her birthday wish, they do,
just in time so see the explosion that would
have killed them.
Throughout the rest of the vacation, Death
comes for each of them.
Kris is chopped up by a boat propeller.
His girlfriend Katie breaks a thermometer
on herself and then trips and falls on some
sharp skeleton bones.
Gino crashes through a glass bottom boat while
scuba diving.
Dreena tries to leave Cancun, but falls off
the jet bridge after it’s struck by a runaway
forklift.
Jeremy falls down during this and also dies.
They’re unable to leave the country with
an incoming Hurricane.
Amanda drowns when the automatic pool cover
turns on while she’s swimming underwater.
Matt’s abs are not strong enough to stand
up to fireworks.
Jake is chopped up by a rescue helicopter.
Bryan tries to hide from the Hurricane in
a coffin, but he never manages to make it out.
And Carly…
Well, I’m not sure exactly what happens to her.
She sees the creepy Shaman in the mirror,
and then… she just kind of disappears.
I don’t know.
Dust in the wind I guess.
After soaking up the sun in Cancun, Death
returns to New York, still needing to take
care of that second list, and see if anything
can be done about the hermit, Clear Rivers.
But before doing that, there are a couple
more disasters with unintended survivors.
One involved 38 year old Doris Fenwick, who
is saved from drowning.
Her fate after that is unknown, but we can
assume Death comes for her.
The other is a larger incident that becomes
known as the infamous Lakeview fire.
We don’t know if it was a premonition that
caused some of the victims to survive this
time, but given the track record of the series,
it probably was.
All of the survivors passed away in what is
described as an eerie string of deaths, but
one of the last survivors was a teenager named
Brian Gibbons.
However, before taking out Brian, Death decides
now is a good time to try to reclaim the lives
of Evan, Tim, Nora, Kat, Rory, Eugene, Clear
and Thomas.
Clear is still in the padded room though,
so she’s off the board for now, so Death’s
new plan is to take out all the others in
a massive highway pileup.
I’ll also note that the order they were
going to die in during the pile up doesn’t
match up with the order in which they were
interfered with by the would-be Flight 180
victims, because that order isn’t necessarily
the order they would have died in.
If that explanation sounds confusing, think
about it like this.
Burke could have gotten shot in that shoot
out, but not died from his injuries for another
couple days.
We don’t know, because we don’t see any
of that.
What I’m trying to say is just don’t worry too much
about the order here.
Death’s designs are thwarted once again
by William Bludworth, who seems to somehow
make contact with a young woman named Kimberly
Corman…
just before her very own Flight
180 style premonition.
Kimberly’s vision not only saves those who
were on that second death list, but also herself,
leading her to basically just be added to
that list.
Also, Death starts working backwards at this
point.
So the last one that should have died in the
Route 23 pile up, Kimberly, is now the first
target.
Why does Death decide to go in reverse here?
This is twice that this set of victims have
gotten away, so it might be to try to catch
them off guard.
Flight 180 has become kind of a mainstream
story at this point, and maybe Death is worried
that the victims are figuring out its MO.
Death comes for Kimberly immediately in the
form of a barreling truck, but Officer Burke
pulls her out of the way, so her spot is skipped
for now.
Evan is crushed by a ladder, Tim is crushed
by a glass pane and Nora is decapitated by
an elevator.
Eugene tries to just give up and take himself
out, but he’s physically unable to do so
because it isn’t his turn, as explained
by Clear, who is now helping the new victims.
I’m not really a fan of this rule, but it
doesn’t matter, this is how it is.
You literally cannot die until death has decided
it’s your turn.
And it’s Kat’s turn.
Her airbag goes off, sending her head into
a sharp pipe.
Rory actually encounters the Lakeview fire
survivor, Brian Gibbons, and saves him from
being hit by a news van, thus extending his
life a little bit longer.
Then, we see the importance of Death taking
them out in the correct order again, because
it actually knocks down a tree branch in order
to move Burke out of the way so he isn’t
hit by the barbed wire fence that slices through
Rory.
Next up is Eugene, who is taken out in an
explosion that also incinerates Clear.
Now you might ask why Clear was able to die
right here if it isn’t her turn?
I think it’s because she’s technically
still on the Flight 180 list.
Not the Route 23 list.
So on that list, it’s been her turn the
entire time; she’s the last one.
With a last ditch plan, Kimberly decides to
drive into a lake, hoping that because she’s
next to the hospital, she would be treated
quickly and someone would be able to revive
her.
This would theoretically invalidate Death’s
list, according to what she was told by Bludworth…
...and her and Burke would be saved.
This is the second theory proposed by Bludworth.
This one actually has a little bit more going
for it, because we’ve now seen Patti Fuller’s
grandmother, Patti Fuller herself, Louise
King and now Kimberly Corman all survive using
this tactic.
It’s possible that they all died shortly
after, but none of them are confirmed dead.
In fact, Kimberly and Burke reunite with the
Gibbons family for a barbecue at the end of
that summer in 2001, and the grill explodes
on Brian, thus wrapping up the list of victims
from the Lakeview fire.
It would be a couple more years until Death
would have to start another list.
I mean, obviously this kind of stuff is probably
always happening off screen, but the next
Final Destination story would be Final Destination:
Death of the Senses taking place in 2003,
a few years after Flight 180.
Jack Curtis was the driver of the bus that
ran over Terry Chaney in 2000.
You know, the one that Kat was also on.
He would lose his job because of this, and
become homeless.
And it is because he is homeless that he’s
in the right place at the right time to save
a police officer named Amy Tom from a serial
killer.
That means all the victims that the serial
killer would have gotten are now safe, so
Death has to take out each of them.
The serial killer is referred to as John Doe,
and yes, he’s very similar to the John Doe
from Se7en, but instead of basing his crimes
on The Seven Deadly sins, he planned to base
them on the five senses.
For sight, he was to take out a beautiful
reporter named Chelsea Cox.
Death gets her with an icicle.
On the air!
"WE'LL DO IT LIVE! F-"
For smell, the target was the man in charge
of municipal trash collection, Dawson Donahue.
His car explodes.
Taste was going to be food critic Dominique Swann.
Death blows up her wine bottle and she’s
choked by a glass shard.
Touch would have been Katie Astin, a talk
show host and televangelist, who was electrocuted.
And for sound, the victim would have been
Joshua Cornell III, a rapper-producer whose
head is cut off when his platinum record is
launched through the air during an equipment
malfunction.
Of course, there is one more, and that is
the officer that Jack saved: Amy Tom.
She is impaled by her own art piece, and then
Jack also dies even though he wasn’t technically
on the list, because Officer Tom’s partner
thought that he was the killer.
Oopsie!
On May 13th 2005, the five year anniversary
of Flight 180, and the four year anniversary
of the Route 23 pile up, there are two more
psychic visions.
I would definitely understand if this is becoming
one of Death’s least favorite days of the
year.
The first is in Miami during Final Destination:
Looks Could Kill.
Woman named Stephanie Pulaski (also known
as Sherry) is part of a modeling group called
“Cellar” where each model is nicknamed
after a different type of wine.
During a party on a yacht called the Coral
Clipper, Sherry has a vision of a fatal crash,
and she convinces her boyfriend and some of
the other models to exit the boat before it
departs.
When the crash occurs for real, a piece of
debris strikes Sherry in the face, sending
her into a coma.
While she was being hospitalized, a similar
disaster would occur further up the Atlantic
coast during a special grad night at McKinley
Park.
That night in McKinley, Pennsylvania, a yearbook
photographer named Wendy Christensen has a
vision about a horrific accident on a roller
coaster called Devil’s Flight.
She causes a scene and several other high
school students get off the ride before it
crashes, but Wendy loses her boyfriend and
her best friend, because their car’s restraints
were not released.
Wendy sees the ominous signs of Death in her
photographs from that night and tries to figure
out their meaning so she can warn each of
the others before they are crossed off of
Death’s newest checklist.
Popular girls Ashley Freund and Ashlyn Halperin
both become victims of a tanning bed incident,
pervert Frankie Cheeks becomes a Motorhead…
and not in the heavy metal kind of way -- and
football star Lewis Romero is all brawns and
no brain…
literally because his head is crushed by a
pair of giant weights.
Wendy and her friend Kevin Fischer are able
to prevent the death of Ian McKinley, so the
next target is his girlfriend Erin, who is
spiked by a nail gun.
Wendy’s sister Julie was also on the ride,
and with the help of Kevin, Wendy’s able
to rescue her, but her friend Perry is not
so lucky and gets impaled by a flagpole.
Wendy and Kevin are both able to dodge death,
so it comes back around to Ian, who is crushed
by a falling sign.
So Wendy, Kevin and Julie are safe… for
now...
In August 2005, Sherry is released from the
hospital stay that began with the yacht crash,
but she’s forced to wear a mask to cover
her now disfigured face, and she thinks her
life is over.
But like Eugene, she’s unable to end it
herself.
She then receives a phone call from Death,
or at the very least, someone or something
posing as Death, who offers to make her a
deal.
We’ve never seen Death be compromising or
try to make a deal with any of the victims
in the series, so I think it stands to reason
that this caller is an imposter.
They meet at a café, where he appears as
an elderly black man.
He asks her to help get rid of the survivors
that should have drowned that day.
In exchange for that, he would restore her
face.
Not only has Death not taken a human form
before, but it’s never really needed help
killing anyone.
A fellow model named Chablis is eaten away
by spilled chemicals.
Shiraz’s scalp is torn off and her head
is twisted around on a music video set.
Chardonnay hits her head and drowns in a hot
tub.
Rose’s organs are vacuumed in a botched
liposuction surgery.
Sherry’s boyfriend, Brut, is run over by
a subway train after falling into a manhole.
And a photographer named Gunter was crushed
after being pinned by the loading platform
of a delivery truck.
For each of these deaths, Sherry has either
played a hand, or watched idly as they happen.
But she can’t bring herself to kill her
best friend Cabernet, and because of this,
she’s broken the deal.
Cabernet is also pregnant, and the delivery
of her child may be what saves her.
Remember the clue...
“Only new life can defeat Death.
The introduction of life that was not meant
to be… that can invalidate the list.
Force Death to start anew.”
We’ve only seen the “new life can defeat
Death” cheat used successfully for people
who were revived, but back in Final Destination
2, Kimberly’s original understanding of
this clue was that if someone who was supposed
to have died creates new life by giving birth,
they would essentially be off the hook.
Anyways, after publicly screaming about her
deal with Death, Sherry is admitted to a psych
ward.
In November, Wendy and Kevin are now in college,
and Julie meets both of them by chance on
the subway when Wendy has another vision.
This time, she sees their train crashing,
but unlike the roller coaster, they aren’t
able to get off.
We don’t see what happens after this, but
there is a possibility that some of them survived,
since every other vision in the series has
resulted in at least one person being saved,
so it stands to reason that these visions
are always a clue about how to avoid the hand
of death.
During the six months that follow Sherry gets
better, and even goes through a facial reconstruction
program.
On May 13th 2006, Sherry is crossing a street
to meet up with Cabernet when she receives
a phone call.
The caller ID simply says: Death, and Sherry
is struck down by a bus.
As you can probably tell, Death seems to be
a gearhead, and loves vehicular accidents.
Just freaking adores them.
So in 2009, the most vehicle oriented disaster
of them all would occur.
The Megatech 300 would be held at the McKinley
Speedway, where a… guy… we don’t really
know what he does, named Nick O’Bannon would
experience his own Flight 180 phenomenon.
He envisions a huge pile up where race cars
crash and tumble into the stands, taking out
many fans, so he pulls his friends away from
the action.
In doing so, he inadvertently starts a fight
and is chased out of the stadium by several
people.
Their lives are saved when his vision comes
true, but Death gets to work quickly.
A woman named Nadia is obliterated by a flying
tire, Carter Daniels is dragged down the street
and lit on fire by his leaking truck, Samantha
is shot in the eye when a lawnmower ejects
a rock, and Andy is diced by a fence.
Nearby, there’s kind of a side disaster
that happens nearby, when an out of control
truck crashes into a coffee shop and runs
over three McKinley High School students.
Nick’s friend Janet is able to avoid Death’s
first attack at the car wash, but their friend
Hunt is not so lucky, as he’s drowned and
sucked into a pool drain.
A man named Jonathan Groves is crushed by
a bathtub that falls through from a floor
above at the hospital, just like Rinoka from
Final Destination: End of the Line, and a
security guard named George is hit by an ambulance.
Just like seemingly half of the population
in this franchise being killed by vehicles.
The remaining three are Nick, his girlfriend
Lori and their friend Janet.
Nick has a new vision, which leads him to
save the girls from an exploding movie theater,
so Death goes back to one of it’s most reliable
methods, and hits them with a truck.
At the time of making this video, this is
the last major death to occur.
So, by going through literally everything,
all 1,458 confirmed kills -- and that’s
not including Carly -- we’ve learned a lot
about the rules and tendencies of Death, but
like the actual concept of death in real life,
there are still some things that we’ll never
understand.
However, in looking at the bigger picture,
we can get a better idea of how this all works.
Here’s what I’ve gathered.
Death is unstoppable.
The only way you may be able to avoid it is
with the introduction of new life that was
never meant to be, but since we never see
any of the characters who tried this later
on down the line, we can’t say with 100%
certainty that this works.
So you can’t avoid it, but you can put it
off.
But if you do cheat Death, don’t expect
it to last long.
The only one who survived for an extended
period was Clear, and she did so by locking
herself away and not really interacting with
anyone, thus not doing anything to change
the course of history in a major way.
The best comparison I can make to the nature
of the Flight 180 phenomenon, is Stephen King’s
11/22/63.
That story involves a teacher named Jake Epping
who goes back in time to try to prevent the
assassination of John F Kennedy.
But he also tries to fix other things while
he’s in the past, which he believes will
make the world a better place in the present.
But whenever he tries to change history, the
universe fights back, and “corrects” whatever
he does.
And this makes it very difficult for him to
change a major historical event, like a presidential
assassination.
So in essence, he’s able to change little
details, but things just get smoothed over
and eventually go unnoticed.
He can’t do much to change the destiny of
the universe.
And I think this is basically how it goes in Final
Destination.
If you have a vision about the future, you
may be able to save yourself for the time
being, but before long, Death will correct
your actions, and you will be the one to pay
the price for it.
Click the video on the left to see my analysis
of other Final Destination characters, and
if you love horror remember to subscribe to
CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
the deathbell for notifications and I’ll
see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
If you want to actually beat death, use a
facemask and social distancing.